what's up guys and gals welcome back to
the corridor digital podcast since you
guys are the true tongs the truest of
the croutons in watching and
participating in this podcast I wanted
to let you know that the merch store has
been restocked that's right before we
even start this episode if you missed
out on the emergency green screen
blanket if you missed out on the mocap
crewneck if you missed out on the
joggers or the back pack or a couple of
the other really awesome items that we
dropped late last year well guess what
they're back in store right now so go on
over to corridor digital dot store and
check those out and let's get on with
this podcast that's right we're going to
talk about AI today and this is a little
bit of a precursor to a couple other
conversations we're gonna have here
where I think the topic of AI super
human government's is gonna be hotly
debated so stick around and find out
how robots are gonna take all of our
jobs third week in a row - the corridor
cast you might notice that we're wearing
some of the same clothes from the
previous episode well you know what
since we were just talking about goal
setting
I think this consistency that we have to
the podcast is going to help us reach
our goal of actually having a real pod
get our goal is to release so this this
is great actually our goal was to
release a podcast once a week this year
so far were three weeks in we've met
that goal every week heck yeah I know
it's gotta keep it up right yeah
consistency keypress what we're
recording two episodes here together so
that we can hit that goal what's our
topic today alright ready before we
start the topic timer starts now we've
got 30 minutes Nico wanted to talk about
machine learning and what he's learned
about the machines learning yeah we're
commonly known as artificial
intelligence yes well are we talking
like calculators here like that memory
button is this what we're totally
talking calculators here what is a
computer tell me about it pewter so what
is a cackler just a big brain in a tiny
little box no wait so what was my actual
prop that wasn't a real prompt
I ask you if you want to do a podcast
and you said yeah I've been discovering
a lot of things about machine learning
and AI I'd love to talk about those on
the podcast and then I said that sounds
like a fun topic why don't we do that
okay cool so machine learning what what
is it first and foremost basically
machine learning is a way for a computer
to learn something on its own and what
you mean but what I mean by that is like
let's say you have a problem that you
want to solve and you're gonna have the
computer solve it let's go with a simple
one green screen right okay so you want
the computer to take everything green
and make it transparent now in the past
how you'd usually do something like that
is you'd go in and you would set the
rules you would say okay everything that
has this value of green in its pixel
give it this much transparency and maybe
I'll expose some bike controls to the
user so like they can change how it's
transparency for green and how much
tolerance I have into like the blues and
the yellows and things like that but
you're solving the problem as the
programmer you're saying okay here's the
math I'm doing the formula here's the
math machine learning on the other hand
all that is abstracted you just give it
a start point and an end point and the
computer figures out everything in
between it's all one big mess of
interconnected neurons and you don't
really know what any of them mean or
what any of them do you can't just like
tweak them yourself afterwards the
computer basically just writes its own
program internally to achieve the end
result that you want and the thing is
this is very similar to how our brains
function with how our neurons work and
so machine learning ends up having a lot
of analogues to like our pattern
recognition process and all these other
like thinking processes and visual
processes that we have and it's like you
know if you seem like a Google deep
dream for example where they you know
everything starts looking like dogs
everywhere it's doing basically pattern
recognition and then matching that
pattern to other pictures and that's
similar to how we see things like you'll
see something you try to recognize a
pattern and apply that to other things
that you know like okay I face two dots
eyes one dot maybe a nose line mouth
okay I got it
it's a face you can recognize that
pattern I could do a whole series of
dots and lines and you can pick out all
the smiley faces in it whereas if you
were to show that just to a camera the
camera doesn't see anything but when you
if you went in and did like machine
learning
and you could train the computer to
recognize faces and in turn just like
how you can recognize the pet those
patterns a computer will work out the
similar way the reason I've been so into
machine learning is what what wait
sari fit yeah keep going the question
when you're done ok the reason I've been
so into machine learning recently is um
you know as you guys know I was doing a
lot of deep faking stuff during the
summer and fall last year and it's not
actually that hard to do machine
learning like to sit down and code
something and like have it have a
computer like then chug and like
calculate a way to like figure out a
problem for you it can get very advanced
and complicated but it not like starting
out it necessarily isn't it's actually
very approachable because like I said
kind of the beauty of it this is a bit
of an oversimplification you can kind of
just give it your end result and the
computer will figure out how to get
there let's say let's say you want to
colorize black-and-white footage and you
want a computer to do that for you
rather than trying to go in and like
manually say like ok anything that looks
like a tree make it green anything that
looks like the sky make it blue like
you're not gonna go in and do any of
that instead what you would feed the
computer is you would feed it
black-and-white images and then you
would have what's kind of called a
ground truth and this is for a certain
type of machine learning there's
different types but let's say you ought
you film your with your camera out
outdoors right you have the color images
it's on your camera so you can do is you
can give the computer to the
black-and-white image you can say hey
try to colorize it it'll try to colorize
it and you show it the actual colorized
image you say how close did you get to
the actual ground truth to the toy I
want what I want you to get and then
computer can look at that bit oh I did a
really bad job this guy is orange or hey
this guy is blue and it's supposed to be
blue okay that one I did better there
and by repeating that process over and
over the computer hones in on some weird
neural network that gets it to spit out
results as close to the ground truth as
possible so you no longer have to go in
and figure out what math to type the
computer figures it out because all you
have to do is give the computer the the
end result the right answer and then the
computer will go through and make its
own guess and see how close to the right
answer it was and then I'll repeat that
billions of times until it hones itself
down to get the right answer as much as
possible so is that the same thing is
like chess when you know the computer
chess masters or go masters I mean a
little bit you can get a little bit in
there but no because chess already has
the rules so you're actually are
programming in the rules there's like
there's not necessarily rules the
machine learning you can you can start
adding some of that to the thing like
hints and you know boundaries and things
like that to help contain you know they
can peer like when I do a deep fake it
goes through another thing first that
marks landmarks in the face like where
the eyes are the nose in the mouth it
doesn't just look like at a blob of
pixels and try to guess for the faces
that steps actually already kind of done
so it has hints to where the eyes and
the nose and the mouth is and where the
general boundaries of the faces are to
help guide it to get a more accurate
results otherwise you can kind of end up
in the ether of trying the computer
trying to solve a problem without any
guidance and it you know sometimes gets
bogged down but you know a chess a
chessboard has rules to it and it has a
certain state that it ends in that you
can that you can mathematically define
really easily and so that's much more of
a you know this piece can only move like
this this piece can only move like this
do a tree of decisions as far as you can
go and figure out which one gives you
the best result and like what is the
best result well capturing more pieces
capture more territories it's up to you
as the programmer to decide and then you
can you can balance that in like in a
way there's a little bit of machine
learning you can do and making those
kind of things and by say making a bunch
of different types of programs and then
having different weights and the
influences of like how important is that
it is it to capture pieces versus how
important is it to capture territory you
can have that computer try different
variations of that office off of itself
and see which one leads to optimal
results and that's in a way a sense of
machine learning but that's not the kind
of machine learning I'm talking about
here yeah theoretically it was like a
chess game too you can basically say all
right we're literally just gonna
calculate every single possible
configuration of pieces that could ever
go on this board and then when you're
doing a game against an opponent
basically each time it hits it's
basically hitting a fork in the road
going alright well there's more wind
potentials down here so I'm just gonna
move because I've already figured out
all the potential moves on the chess
board yeah make sense so the tricky
thing about chess is that you can't
calculate all the potential moves
because there's too many it's like the
number of potential moves from the
beginning of a game of chess is like
more than there are atoms in the
universe you can calculate out to like
seven or eight moves down for other
possibilities and then it's like yeah
that is too much to figure out and shows
how much I know I guess okay it's the
right start but then you can't want to
go like okay so what state do I want to
kind of get into that's ideal and then
from there I'll do a new tree once we
get to that that point you know we've
made a lot of assumptions going into
this conversation I need clarity on
hey I hadn't gotten to my really into it
yet we'll get to that you started this
conversation by saying a machine
learning is what occurs when I come when
you want when a computer teaches its
self something so let's just boil that
phrase down for a second at what point
because a computer originally you know
actually was a computer I mean it still
is but it's just like two plus two
equals four so at what point doesn't
Mitch does a machine a computer learn
something on its own so that's wait wait
where does that occur because it hasn't
that already occurred up to this point
it has an arguably like computers can be
learning in a lot of different ways I
think it makes machine learning special
is the computers figuring out the
solution on how to get like how to get
to that solution on its own like there's
a lot of different ways you can train a
computer you can have a computer do work
for you but machine learning special in
that you're not the one going in typing
in the code that says ok run these tests
to solve the problem the computer
figures out internally what tests to run
this also at some point some human went
in and was like ok normal computer
function does this you give it a series
of parameters it tries to solve the
problem and then when it can't solve it
it just stops so then somebody went in
and was like program to go back to the
start and then a variable rate basically
like you know the the monkeys and
typewriters scenario given an infinite
amount of monkeys and an infinite amount
of typewriters eventually one monkey
will type all the works of Shakespeare
sure yeah oh I've heard that in
different and different analogies but
yeah I mean basically the idea is that
if you are randomly generating letters
right at some point your random
assortment of letters if you have
infinity time and right any
possibilities and eventually though
zombies in an organized state word like
they happen to be arranged in the same
way as you know a play of Shakespeare
hacking passwords works I mean it can be
when you brute force it you're just
going through all possible combinations
ok so so at some point so just so we get
to just bring me up to current
technology let me finish answering your
question the reason we get the monkey
thing is because the computer is
basically the monkeys mashing on the
keyboards right but then you also have a
test in there so you have the actual
script of Shakespeare and so you're
constantly looking in be like ok this
one's way off it doesn't have numbers
letters and it's just only numbers okay
that monkey is take it out back and and
so even though it's kind of getting
there and they're not really words yet
at least they kind of are structured
like words that monkey
let's give it a monkey wife and see how
many monkey babies they can put out
right and that's base what the computer
is doing is it's you know it's just this
random mush but you have a an end goal
and when something kind of as close to
that you go okay let's do more of that
but let's continue mutating it a little
bit all this even close for us can you
take that a little bit more oh yeah I
could mean other he's a little bit
closer let's mutate that a little bit
more and you're basically going through
generations I was almost like evolution
in a way yeah that make sense but I
think the main thing that is hard to get
your head wrapped around though is the
stuff that happens in between there
because it's so it's so like the
colorization thing for example I mean
realistically let's say you are tasked
with colorizing an image you have a
black-and-white image of human
approaches it well you have to isolate
objects you have to recognize what those
objects are and then you have to know
what those real-world colors of those
objects are and so I guess when you're
programming a programming for that
programming machine learning to do that
task is that basically I guess the tasks
you need to assign to it like those are
the skills that needs to have you know
do you tell the the algorithm ahead of
time that those are the tasks you'll
need for this job and these you need you
need basically object identification
well yeah or or is that even part of the
machine learning itself well it's like
you need to be a little bit specific and
help the computer a little bit you know
it's definitely not like a here I'm just
going to give you every problem and
you'll come up with every solution if I
let you think about it long enough like
you don't we need to like give it some
direction but I mean the thing that has
me really excited about machine learning
is that we have the potential here to
perhaps internally develop plugins that
can do rotoscoping automatically or can
do camera stabilization or can do
colorization or even like highlight
retention or upping highlights back in
on low dynamic range footage like all
these are like you could theoretically
make machine learning I mean machine
learning system where you give it a
frame from a movie and it gives you back
a lookup table that you can apply to any
footage you want to make it look like
the color grid from that movie dude I
feel like we need to hire a programmer
corridor rnd and there's just a dude in
like a closet just crunching like Nikko
to like crunching in the corner music
like oh and then put them in a closet
it's actually last week I actually I
emailed Josh Davies over at FX home
they make no hit film and ignite which a
bunch of plugins and stuff like that and
we're bombarding him yeah to ask him
about you know if they want to try to
develop some machine learning plugins
because there's already a rotoscope
plugin out called roto bot but it's a
little rough around the edges and the
guy is clearly like a one-man team I'm
not sure how much actual VFX work he's
done but some of these things just like
in the hands of I mean not I could go on
but I don't to get into specifics yet
because I feel like we're still kind of
covering the broad topic of the magic
that is machine learning here well here
my yeah I mean I think you get you're
getting into some interesting stuff but
my other thing was regarding these these
quote-unquote neurons
what so apparent but at what point did
computers start creating nodes of
neurons and and of code over there I
mean theoretically that was all possible
since day one but like you know in the
early days of computers you can maybe
have like five neurons and then you
balance them out but obviously you need
more of that web to like have anything
complex there wasn't until GPUs really
became prevalent and powerful cuz he
fused Armada basic just do as many
calculations as possible
it wasn't until then that we could
actually just back okay here's a million
neurons how what see what we get out of
this complex web of just like weights
and balances it's like you know it in
life when you are making a judgment call
you're weighing and balancing different
things right in the complexity of how
much you can weigh and balance and run
things through situations reflects kind
of how sophisticated your final answer
is mm-hmm there's kind of a similar
thing with with computers when when
you're doing you know AI development
machine learning the more neurons you
can make in the more sophisticated the
layers in your machine learning network
are you know the more sophisticated your
answer can be you know it takes actual
it takes a memory computer memory to
store a picture so doing a 64 by 64
pixel picture versus a you know 1080p
picture like that's a big memory
difference and when you have a million
nodes that need to run
million pictures you know there's only
so high of a resolution you can get with
something like that so that's
fascinating yeah I understand
ultimately both it like at the same time
why people would be so afraid of machine
learning and and also so interested in
and and and desiring of it because it's
it's it's almost like it will become its
own life-form in a way yeah Jake you
wanna know something creepy what there's
a documentary on some AI stuff I forget
the name of it but at one point they had
a little robot yeah
then it was teaching himself how to do
you know basic stuff that they told it
to focus on yeah and when they checked
on it day to week later whatever it
developed a facial recognition ability
that they never told it to do right so
it's just like popping off all these
likes so what was so we just real quick
and you can go back to the actual
practicality of this but just thought
you know you kind of need to approach
this like like like a like a human being
in a way in the sense of in the sense of
I mean say as machine learning evolves
because what you wouldn't do to a human
being is say well human beings have
propensity for the utmost evil so we
must lock them all up you know know and
you also wouldn't say well human beings
have a propensity for the utmost good so
we must give them everything on earth I
feel like why would computers be any
different yeah I mean thing is I really
like something like oai it's gonna
become super intelligent and just become
another you know sentient organism it's
like well no that's your
anthropomorphizing AI right everything
is its own thing and there's parallels
and there's similarities but like AI is
effectively pure optimization right it's
the quickest way to achieve an answer or
the truth of something yesyes it because
it can calculate way more than we can
yeah but Jake I think I understand your
example but you know the problem is that
we're still hypothesizing on like the
speed at which it would learn so imagine
you have a child
he just got born and you're like at
school he's a child and then you know
day one he can't
walk day 2 he's crawling around and
you're like oh well I'd better put up
these fences and then day 3 he's 20
years old and living in a cage because
and and so now suddenly the problem is
you've skipped all these steps of things
you're supposed to teach it and I think
that's what people are concerned about
is like the idea of like alright well if
it's so quick at learning it could
outpace the like things the safety nets
we put in place for it is depending on
the stages it's at and so manatee yes
yeah and so it's like well how do you
put in place things that like the
constraints it needs to learn to not
basically take over like a power thing I
never thought about that
yeah because it's like it's gonna be out
of our control and so suddenly you've
got this thing that's intelligent and
you've now taught it and like you've
thought you thought it was a lot more
immature so you put these artificial
constraints on it and but it it already
subverts all that stuff yeah because it
gets to it and so it's like how do you
can how do you control its development
in a positive way well I think people's
fears of AI is a little bit misplaced
it's not like yeah I was going to invent
going to like come to conclusion that
human beings are the Eenie fish and wipe
out human beings like that's that's not
how it's going to go I think the what
people don't really realize is AI is
much more like oh the AI figured out
what kind of videos like to watch on
YouTube perfectly so now you are
spending 12 hours a day watching youtube
vid thats the AI like that's yeah people
don't understand but that's the actual
machine learning thing here it's like
you spending 3 hours a day on YouTube
that's that's the AI stealing your time
you know because it's been perfectly
it's been watching you and following you
in all the other thousands of people
that watch the same thing you watch that
had the same taste as you do in studying
all of you and that's giving you you
know the pure sugar stream right into
yeah exactly and as a note though that's
why you should subscribe to the corridor
cast if you're not subscribed for some
bizarre reason because if you're not
subscribed then you might fall prey very
problem that niko is discussing an
algorithm bought is tricking you into
watching this but we know it was your
decision like what you're describing is
what was it Sam was it it was the step
before general intelligence it was
narrow intelligence intelligence yeah
it's good at one
thing you know or to earn arrow and tell
just like it's good at everything kind
of I'm sorry
intelligence is everything from Tesla's
autopilot to Google's YouTube algorithm
things like it's isolated tasks general
intelligence is when it's good at
something like things generally it's
good at all things general you can adapt
it finding new things you get good at
being good at everything it's about
being able to solve any problem you
throughout it give me enough time to
figure it out
yes I think it'll set goals and create a
disciplined as to those goals it doesn't
I don't know whoa I mean its whole life
is glass I don't think we're at general
intelligence right now we're not that
we're not know red Narrows yeah
absolutely
the thing is like AI is not good at
creating it's good at learning it's not
good at creating and that's the one
thing that human beings and any living
organism tend to really do well still a
great example is AI dungeon so if you
haven't been to node and scenery a
dungeon videos you go check them out a
game has been doing the illustrations
for them there they are incredible and
especially checking out those videos
after listening to this conversation
it's a it's an amazing follow up yes so
what they did for AI dungeon is they
trained an AI to guess the next word
after a series of words so for example
Sam it when I say the sky is blank fill
in the blank on fire no one would ever
say that non prompt it in the middle is
coercive right despite feeling the most
likely where the sky is blank blue okay
cool give me another one this guy is
blank black I should give you guys more
context here killing the most likely
BOTS we failed on fire just compared it
to the answer and you're like try again
so specifically one trying to say here's
you know tell anyone of you to film the
booth I'm fill in the blank with the
most likely answer this guy's blank or
the grass is blank
Green long-dead around on fire you know
whatever but you would say the grass is
doggy the grass is banana like you throw
a random word now if you give a computer
and you're like yes and the computer
like here's my dictionary words and it
just throws that a random word you know
that's what's gonna happen at first bad
computer bad computer so what they did
is they actually they took a computer
and they had it you know they would feed
it words and I'd try to guess the next
word and they went through I think it's
like 17 million webpages and a little
bit of the thing is you have the ground
truth right there you have the actual
word that's hidden for the computer in
your reveal after it's like oh how close
were you oh you got it right cool
whatever you did to get it right keep
doing that and they went through they
did that for 17 million my have been 7
million either way it's a lot even they
did that until the computer was really
good at basically just contextually
guessing the next word in a series of
words which us as human beings are
pretty good actually we've actually
spent our entire lives learning the
exact same thinking yeah exactly
so you know you can throw any sentence
at somebody and they'll you know have a
good guess of how to finish it and if
eat if they don't guess what it's
supposed to finish like at least it'll
sound right you know you're not just
gonna throw it a nonsense word into
there and that's why this computer this
algorithm is a I ended up being able to
do is being able to have sensical
sentences and not just word for word but
a whole paragraphs or multiple
paragraphs because you know it was able
to hold all that in its memory whereas
in the past my only be able to hold a
sentence or two now it can hold multiple
paragraphs now the people that made this
got kind of worried because you
basically have a content generator here
that can just spit out web page after
web page of just fluff [ __ ] for
people that then put ads on a basic
break the internet with which is kind of
already happening once again wait hold
on again what do you mean like you just
be like I want to have a website that
just generates pages for clicks so I can
get ad revenue so I'm just gonna have it
literally make up web page after web
page after web page of like just
randomly generated content but it'll all
sound kind of like it was written by a
human being but then once you read a
paragraph or two you realize it's just
this weird dreamlike nonsense just like
that's only aware of its own context and
just runs on and basically you're making
AI headlines with AI yeah yeah content
if I wrote like whoa a new Tesla
automobile is a car that you should be
watching out for and I just let the AI
fill in the rest of the article and it's
not gonna actually say anything like
of the value it'll appear it'll appear
like you'll start reading it okay
alright where's this going at what this
is if there's no information yet and
then you finish it and you're like
that's nonsense
yes which is kind of how a a dungeon
works and so AI dungeon is a text-based
choose-your-own-adventure game and the
thing is it so it's prompted with the
paragraph that's already written it's
always the same paragraph and the
computer just starts generating
contextual text after that but you write
your prompts and what's actually
happening is that's just being treated
the same as all the rest of the the text
as context so if you write you know I
grabbed my big sword and I fight the
dragon that appears like well
contextually speaking the next thing
should probably be so he fights the
dragon and the fiery breath burns his
skin you know it's like it's just gonna
guess like that contextually sounds
right based on what you were typing and
what I've already typed the thing is
it's only trained off of all these short
stories that people have written so all
these clever twists and turns it's not
the computer making that up those are
just from all the stories as it pulls
out the little pieces here and there
those little twists and turns have been
created by people so so that's the input
yeah so the computer's not coming up
with cleverness the computer is just
regurgitating contextually correct
sounding stuff but the cool ideas like
the good prose and the funny twists and
like you know the character are speaking
in a certain way or having a cool name
those are the human beings that invented
that so in a way like the AI is good at
remix it's not good at inventing machine
learning is good at REE mixing but it
can't just invent something from nothing
that's up to the human beings but we
have 6 billion no cellar sorry 7 billion
almost 8 billion human beings on the
planet and we've been inventing stuff
for years and years and years and years
and much for this now digitized so
there's these vast oceans of just
content that the AI can remix and no
one's aware of it ok two things this is
this whole thing about the webpage is
breaking the internet because of cliques
mm-hmm is exactly a main reason but we
need to get we need to diversify I'm not
saying get rid of but we need to
diversify away from the clique based
economy yes on the internet its needs to
do that yeah and I feel like with Google
Adsense that has made the internet you
have to do it was a great it's a great
it was a great model to start thing
yeah I was now into like to like get the
rest of the internet like monetized and
to like create actual economic
structures that are protected and and
consistent but it's it's now we're now
we're seeing all these other problems
that no one thought of it that's yeah
it's like have you ever tried to read a
news article just like get something
that you need to search for right these
days it is a mess it is literally just
some intern regurgitating an article at
some other intern role just
regurgitating an article at some other
intern row and they're all putting about
20 minutes of effort into it yeah and
it's going down the hole like thousands
layers of deep so that's that's the
neuro lateral yeah we got a diversify
away from that I think there's always
gonna be a fundamental like niche or not
even a niche but a fundamental sector
that that clique based like content well
will people just need to get tired of it
yeah they'll get tired of it also you
need to move away from my kids to be
monetized through other ways you know
what is basically founded on
prioritizing search for results by use
believe what Tom Hanks's child looks
like do you think popular think is more
popular no no not just that but popular
if you click on something that's
directly tied to a fraction of a penny
being paid for that click and and and
that's that's the that's the economic
system that basically Google and then
followed by Facebook has been created on
the internet and I'm saying
that is only one model for information
on the Internet and a way to pay to
create that information right I think to
pay to create content to pay to create
news to all these all these things that
serve a fundamental human need
entertainment good accurate information
right like a place to like store
documents and trade documents and
exchange data right all of these things
there's different economies that you can
that you can attach to all these
different services that the Internet can
do all these different functions that it
can do but they the main issue is that
yeah from Google's perspective it's
neutral so it's like the quality of the
content isn't relative to how its
prioritizing stuff necessarily and I
think that's I mean that's big only
become a public discussion over the like
the last two years or so yeah
you know with all these things with how
Google is now starting to like rate
information at least and kind of get
itself out there a little more but but
yeah that's basically the the
consequence of that could I hit you guys
with an out-there concept perhaps to
wrap up this one I want I want to I want
to feel like I'm flying through space
out there we've got three minutes left
all right so you guys know you know the
main steps in like you know biology you
have cells cells makeup systems you know
organs if you will various organ systems
make them an organism which is generally
a complex life form you know initially
life rooms just cells cells would work
together and kind of form these little
organelles or not organelles but like
you know basically organs and the organs
function together to make a whole
organism function of liver cells and
heart cells and they run the heart and
they're on the liver each cell is in of
its in and of itself an individual life
form in case you guys missed biology
class guys but knows it like I am NOT
one thing I am actually you know
millions of little individual living
organisms all working together and yet
somehow I have a singular consciousness
right only Niko gets credit so you know
we go on one wheel rides all the time
and we will go to the top of mountains
and I mean we in alone just know you
have an audience of millions but you
have to top these nuns and you know
usually we're sitting around looking at
the city
[Laughter]
are you flying through space look at the
highways and it's like those are like
veins and arteries and you get the
little side streets or like lean on the
capillaries and stuff like that and you
have the electric grid which is like the
you know not necessarily same thing but
it's like the nerves and you have like
the communication grids and basically
you know from up high on top of mountain
you know all of us individual people
working together we looks like we're
building a lichen or like a organic mold
that lives on the ground right with
veins and pathways you know just like
your body has you know veins for
transporting you know your blood and
your oxygens like that know like and
waste routes and you have you know your
communication you have your structural
things you know build up your body this
is all you know individual cells working
together and you kind of abstract it and
like I said this is another thought but
just rolling on this you know when you
look at the city from the air it's kind
of like every person is just a cell
working together to make these organs in
these organs then run the giant organism
and that giant organism is basically the
city or rather the entire infrastructure
that we've connected together across the
entire land mass of the planet so like
burbank's a lung and like friggin
pasadena is like a kidney I would say
the cities are more like the organisms
but like the power plant Burbank is like
you know the heart or whatever so how do
you how do you send this up where I mean
that's like matrix that's like kind of
what's happened that's kind of what's
happening right so you maybe there's an
argument that you know a city is kind of
like an organism but at a different
definition but here's I'm going with
this
so eventually organisms get complicated
enough to start a thought process
everything's working together start a
thought process and arguably we are
starting that era now as they take
computers and start turning them into AI
is that can problem solve and think for
themselves and they're not gonna think
in the same way that you or I think they
think differently but us as cells are
finally building this organ that can
finally have a central thought system
and the eventually ethicists thought
system might be all the connected neural
networks of different computers and you
know different algorithms and AI they're
all done running together to give this
thing a consciousness because I can see
in a hundred years from now in AI
dictates what happens in the city oh
this is the most efficient route that
you should drive to clean the garbage
this is the most efficient thing that I
totally I redo my repairs
we welcome it I totally agree and I
thought about this now that I know where
you've gone with this
I completely agree so as I think the
concept of an AI government is that the
coolest thing in the world government
it's not a kindness AI government it's
like going to be no it will though but
imagine the fact like imagine me no I
just imagine a world where AI is smart
enough when we rely on it enough to be
able to take this weight off of
humanity's shoulders of all this dumb
political bickering and like and and put
this decision-making process into a
truly intelligent neutral third party
this is all coming you cannot remove
though I agree that that would be great
and there's probably a function for that
as well as for the city trucks what you
guys are leaving out here and when I
think often gets left out and in an all
this conversation is that like the
entire infrastructure of our entire
society at least in well pretty much
throughout the world is built on
people's sovereign individual out
individuality like if we all just you
don't just like think about your driving
down the road like right maybe this will
go away with autonomous cars but it'll
just manifest somewhere else right like
you can you are you are choosing to stay
in the lane yes right and you are
choosing to like get up and you're
choosing to do the right thing and
you're choosing to do all these things
like the entire fabric of civilization
is built on that and so I don't know if
like it would be cut like communist I
don't know how you have a choice to do
this still gonna embrace I'm saying is
like the mentor to a ground truth it
still needs to embrace like this ability
of like an individual like you know
doing something and not just being like
an autonomous car there's not gonna be
like a [ __ ] mode you can hit a button
it goes [ __ ] mode and then drives
aggressively these like things don't I
definitely think we need to come back
and have an AI government like debate we
should
another podcast hey government and like
break that down alright guys next
question Jake oh do you know what the
most do you know which biological trait
is most associated with high functioning
logical intelligence biological trait I
guess it's kind of biologically it's
really two life-forms it has is if
there's this one trait that's
sophisticated in animals it correlates
the most with having also highly
intelligent high functioning logical
reasoning and animals probably like huge
beers tools or something I have no idea
is the concepts a little abstract from
social interaction ah yes the more an
animal has complicated social
interaction the higher its logical
reasoning abilities that's yeah Birds
the more logical Birds have very
complicated social societal systems same
with doll father animals yep and same
with human beings and so even though you
are a sovereign individual Jake can't
but help it's in your nature you have
heavy societal pressure course yeah but
I think with a part of being a sovereign
individual is like understanding you you
have you have to interact with people to
understand like yes like that's how you
that's how you reach your full potential
everyone is a sovereign individual but I
think the instinctual pressures of
society weigh upon us far more greatly
this is so threaded right now guys come
back next week we're gonna be doing a
government I get it you're one of the
guys who goes on YouTube and immediately
click subscription before any videos
loaded from very little context our time
is up I'm sorry we got it you gotta join
us next this is the cliffhanger consider
subscribing unfinished business
legit from a central organism that
thinks for itself and we are all just
cells and that each other robe on masks
on for the next one and a helmet
consider subscribing
yeah so you have great times next time
we can't wait to talk about this is the
yeah okay after all this podcast